Le solveur quantique variationnel de valeurs propres, ou VQE, est l'un des premiers algorithmes hybrides quantique-classique et il est
intéressant pour plusieurs raisons. Premièrement, comme nous le verrons dans cette vidéo, c'est une approche prometteuse pour certains types de problèmes. Deuxièmement, il est important
historiquement et a ouvert la voie à de nombreux algorithmes améliorés tels que ADAPT-VQE.
Et enfin, le VQE est assez simple. Il est facile de comprendre ce que les ordinateurs quantique et classique font dans cet algorithme
et comment ils interagissent. Il y a quatre composantes principales dans un calcul VQE.
Premièrement, il y a un opérateur, souvent un hamiltonien, que nous appellerons H, qui décrit une propriété du système que
tu souhaites optimiser. Autrement dit, tu cherches le vecteur propre de cet opérateur qui
correspond à la valeur propre minimale. Nous appelons souvent ce vecteur propre l'état fondamental.
Ensuite, il y a un ansatz, mot signifiant « approche ». C'est un circuit quantique qui prépare un état quantique approximant
le vecteur propre que tu cherches. En réalité, l'ansatz est une famille de circuits quantiques car certaines gates dans
l'ansatz sont paramétrées. C'est-à-dire qu'elles reçoivent un paramètre que nous pouvons faire varier. Cette famille de circuits quantiques
peut préparer une famille d'états quantiques approximant l'état fondamental.
Ensuite, nous avons besoin d'un estimateur, un moyen d'estimer la valeur d'expectation de l'opérateur H sur l'état quantique
variationnel courant. Parfois, ce qui nous intéresse vraiment, c'est simplement cette valeur d'expectation, que nous
appelons fonction de coût. D'autres fois, nous nous intéressons à une fonction plus complexe qui peut néanmoins s'écrire à partir
d'une ou plusieurs valeurs d'expectation.
Enfin, nous avons besoin d'un optimiseur classique, un algorithme qui fait varier les paramètres pour essayer de minimiser cette fonction de coût.
Décrivons le problème que nous voulons résoudre et l'approche générale avant d'aborder le rôle du quantique. Nous
pouvons formuler de nombreux problèmes d'optimisation essentiels pour la science et l'industrie comme des problèmes de valeurs propres de matrices. Couramment, tu
veux la valeur propre minimale de ta matrice et le vecteur propre qui lui correspond. La matrice H pourrait être
un hamiltonien décrivant l'énergie d'un système physique. Et la valeur propre minimale serait l'énergie de l'état fondamental
E0 et le vecteur propre serait l'état quantique fondamental correspondant, souvent noté psi indice 0.
Ou la matrice pourrait décrire une fonction de coût complexe associée à des problèmes d'optimisation combinatoire,
comme en logistique, et l'état propre s indice opt serait une solution optimale du
problème, comme une chaîne binaire étiquetant une coupe dans un graphe d'un réseau de distribution. En pratique, il est
courant d'entendre le terme hamiltonien utilisé pour toutes les matrices d'intérêt, même en dehors des sciences physiques. Supposons que
nous nous intéressions à une matrice de n lignes et n colonnes. De tels problèmes peuvent être résolus rapidement et exactement avec des
solveurs classiques pour n allant jusqu'à quelques centaines ou milliers, sans hypothèse sur la matrice. Pour les matrices
creuses, celles dont la plupart des entrées sont des zéros, cela peut être bien plus grand, avec n allant jusqu'à un milliard, même sur un ordinateur portable.
Mais pour des problèmes véritablement énormes qui dépassent ces nombres, des méthodes approximatives ou heuristiques sont souvent nécessaires.
Plus la matrice est grande et moins elle est creuse, moins le problème est traitable et plus il faut employer des astuces. Suppose que ta matrice soit si
grande que la diagonalisation exacte n'est pas une option. Suppose de plus que tu connaisses suffisamment ton problème pour
faire des hypothèses sur la structure globale de l'état cible, et que tu veuilles sonder des états similaires à ta supposition
initiale pour voir si ton coût ou ton énergie peut être encore réduit. C'est une approche variationnelle, et c'est une méthode
utilisée quand la diagonalisation exacte n'est pas possible avec un ordinateur classique. Voici comment cela fonctionne.
D'abord, tu fais un état initial avec des paramètres thêta que tu vas faire varier.
Bien que cette estimation initiale puisse être aléatoire, ce n'est pas conseillé. Nous voulons utiliser la connaissance du problème en question
pour adapter notre estimation autant que possible.
Deuxièmement, nous calculerions la valeur d'expectation de l'opérateur avec le système dans cet état.
Troisièmement, nous modifierions les paramètres variationnels et répéterions.
Quatrièmement, nous utiliserions les informations accumulées sur le paysage des états possibles dans notre sous-espace variationnel pour faire des
estimations de plus en plus précises et nous approcher de l'état cible.
Le principe variationnel garantit que notre état variationnel ne peut pas donner une valeur propre inférieure à celle de
l'état fondamental cible. Donc plus la valeur d'expectation est basse, meilleure est notre approximation de l'état fondamental.
Parlons de la difficulté de chaque étape de cette approche.
Définir ou mettre à jour les paramètres est facile en termes de calcul. La difficulté réside dans le choix de paramètres initiaux
utiles et physiquement motivés. Utiliser les informations accumulées des itérations précédentes pour mettre à jour les paramètres de façon
à se rapprocher de l'état fondamental n'est pas trivial. Mais il existe des algorithmes d'optimisation classique qui le font
assez efficacement. Cette optimisation classique n'est coûteuse que parce qu'elle peut nécessiter de nombreuses
itérations. Dans le pire des cas, le nombre d'itérations peut croître exponentiellement avec n.
L'étape la plus coûteuse en calcul est presque certainement la valeur d'expectation de ta matrice avec un
état donné. La matrice n par n doit agir sur le vecteur de n éléments, ce qui correspond à un ordre de n au carré
opérations de multiplication dans le pire des cas. Cela doit être fait à chaque itération de paramètres. Pour des matrices
extrêmement grandes, cela a un coût de calcul élevé. Maintenant, imagine déléguer cette portion du
calcul à un ordinateur quantique. Au lieu de calculer cette valeur d'expectation, tu l'estimes en préparant
l'état s de thêta sur l'ordinateur quantique en utilisant ton ansatz variationnel, puis en faisant des mesures.
Décortiquons cela un peu. H n'est généralement pas facile à mesurer. Par exemple, il pourrait être composé de nombreux
opérateurs de Pauli X, Y et Z qui ne commutent pas.
Mais H peut s'écrire comme une combinaison linéaire de termes H indice alpha, dont chacun est facilement mesurable. Par exemple,
des opérateurs de Pauli ou des groupes d'opérateurs de Pauli commutant bit par bit. La
valeur d'expectation de H sur l'état S est la somme pondérée des valeurs d'expectation des termes constitutifs H alpha.
Cette expression est valable pour tout état S, mais nous l'utiliserons spécifiquement avec notre état variationnel s de thêta.
Chacun des termes H alpha peut être mesuré m fois, produisant des échantillons de mesure s indice alpha j avec j allant de
1 à m, et renvoie une valeur d'expectation et un écart-type. Nous pouvons additionner
ces termes et propager les erreurs à travers la somme.
Cela ne nécessite aucune multiplication à grande échelle ni aucun processus qui croît nécessairement comme n au carré. Au lieu de cela,
cela nécessite plusieurs mesures sur l'ordinateur quantique. Si tu n'en as pas besoin de trop, cette approche peut être
efficace. Et c'est la partie quantique du VQE. Mais parlons des raisons pour lesquelles cela pourrait ne pas être efficace. Une raison
de faire beaucoup de mesures est de réduire l'incertitude statistique dans tes estimations pour des calculs de très haute
précision. Une autre raison est le nombre de chaînes de Pauli nécessaires pour couvrir l'ensemble de ta matrice. Parce que les matrices de Pauli plus
l'identité engendrent l'espace de tous les opérateurs d'une dimension donnée, nous avons la garantie
de pouvoir écrire notre matrice d'intérêt comme une somme pondérée d'opérateurs de Pauli comme nous l'avons fait précédemment. Ici, C alpha est un
coefficient numérique et H alpha est une chaîne d'opérateurs de Pauli agissant sur tous les qubits décrivant ton système.
H alpha aurait une forme comme celle-ci, où le n-ième opérateur de Pauli en partant de la droite agit sur le n-ième qubit. Nous pouvons donc
mesurer notre opérateur en mesurant une série d'opérateurs de Pauli. Mais nous ne pouvons pas mesurer tous ces opérateurs de Pauli
simultanément. Les opérateurs de Pauli, à l'exclusion de l'identité, ne commutent pas entre eux s'ils sont
associés au même qubit. Par exemple, nous pouvons mesurer I Z, IIZ et ZZ
simultanément parce que nous pouvons mesurer I et Z simultanément pour le troisième
qubit. Et nous pouvons connaître I et X simultanément pour le premier qubit. Mais nous ne pouvons pas
mesurer tout Z et ZZ ZX simultanément parce que Z et X ne
commutent pas et agissent tous deux sur le qubit zéro.
Nous décomposons donc notre matrice H en une somme de Paulis agissant sur différents qubits.
Certains éléments de cette somme peuvent être mesurés en même temps. Nous appelons cela un groupe de Paulis commutants. Selon
le nombre de termes qui ne commutent pas, nous pouvons avoir besoin de nombreux groupes de ce type. Appelons le nombre de ces groupes de Paulis
commutants T.
Si T est petit, cela peut bien fonctionner.
Si H a des millions de groupes, cela ne sera pas utile. Tu enregistres la valeur d'expectation ou la fonction de coût
pour l'ensemble de paramètres thêta utilisé dans ton état, puis tu mets à jour les paramètres au fil du temps. Tu pourrais utiliser les
valeurs d'expectation ou les valeurs de la fonction de coût que tu as estimées pour approximer un gradient de ta fonction de coût dans le
sous-espace d'états échantillonnés par ton ansatz.
Des optimiseurs classiques basés sur le gradient et sans gradient existent. Les deux souffrent de problèmes potentiels d'entraînabilité comme
des minima locaux multiples et de grandes régions de l'espace des paramètres avec un gradient quasi nul, appelées plateaux stériles.
Alors, le VQE résoudra-t-il tous tes problèmes les plus difficiles ? Non. Mais être meilleur dans tous les calculs n'a jamais été le but. Nous avons
déplacé ce qui détermine le coût de calcul. Regarde ce que nous avons échangé. Nous sommes passés d'un processus
dont la complexité ne dépend que de la dimension de la matrice à un processus qui dépend de la précision requise et du nombre
d'opérateurs de Pauli non commutants qui composent la matrice. Ce dernier point n'a pas d'analogue en informatique classique.
Sur la base de ces nouvelles dépendances, pour les matrices creuses ou les matrices impliquant peu de chaînes de Pauli non commutantes, ce
processus peut être utile. C'est le cas pour les systèmes de spins en interaction. Par exemple, pour les matrices denses, cela peut être
moins utile. Nous savons, par exemple, que les systèmes chimiques ont souvent des hamiltoniens impliquant des centaines, des milliers, voire des
millions de chaînes de Pauli. Des travaux intéressants ont été faits pour réduire ce nombre de termes, mais
les systèmes chimiques sont peut-être mieux adaptés à d'autres algorithmes que nous aborderons dans ce cours.
L'utilisation efficace du VQE nécessite aussi de connaître les attributs de notre état cible et de pouvoir sélectionner un bon état
initial physiquement motivé ainsi qu'un bon ansatz avec relativement peu de paramètres variationnels. Cela peut être
assez difficile. Le VQE démontre comment les forces des ordinateurs classiques et quantiques peuvent être combinées.
Sans les méthodes plus récentes, le VQE ne nous aide pas à résoudre des problèmes intraitables pour les ordinateurs classiques, mais
il continue à jouer un rôle dans le développement d'algorithmes. Et le VQE nous enseigne aussi que transférer une étape du classique
vers le quantique n'est ni meilleur ni pire en toutes circonstances. Au contraire, cela
change les facteurs qui déterminent l'efficacité de ton algorithme. C'est une leçon importante en informatique
hybride quantique-classique.